Traductor: Ciro Gomez
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
"La razón es inmortal,
todo lo demás es mortal" Pitágoras
Que tienen Euclides
Einstein, de doce años,
y el presidente estadounidense
James Garfield, en común?
Todos presentaron pruebas elegantes
para el famoso teorema de Pitágoras,
la regla que dice que
en un triángulo rectángulo,
el cuadrado de un lado más
el cuadrado del otro lado
es igual al cuadrado de la hipotenusa.
En otras palabras, a² + b² = c².
Esta afirmación es una de las reglas
más fundamentales de la geometría
y la base para aplicaciones prácticas
como la construcción de edificios estables
y la triangulación de coordenadas del GPS.
El teorema se llama así por Pitágoras,
un filósofo griego y matemático
del siglo VI aC,
pero se conocía hacía más de mil años.
Una tableta babilónica de alrededor
de 1800 aC lista 15 series de números
que satisfacen el teorema.
Algunos historiadores especulan que
los agrimensores egipcios antiguos
utilizaban uno de esos conjuntos,
el 3, 4, 5, para hacer esquinas cuadradas.
La teoría es que los topógrafos
extendían una cuerda anudada
con 12 segmentos iguales
para formar un triángulo
con lados de longitud 3, 4 y 5.
Según lo que dice el teorema de Pitágoras,
esto tiene que hacer
un triángulo rectángulo,
y, por lo tanto, una esquina cuadrada.
Y los primeros textos
matemáticos indios conocidos
escritos entre 800 y 600 aC
establecen que una cuerda estirada
a través de la diagonal de un cuadrado
produce un cuadrado dos veces mayor
que el original.
Esa relación puede derivarse
del teorema de Pitágoras.
Pero ¿cómo sabemos
que el teorema es verdadero
para cada triángulo recto
sobre una superficie plana,
no solo los que estos matemáticos
y topógrafos conocían?
Porque podemos demostrarlo.
Las pruebas usan las reglas
matemáticas y la lógica existentes
para demostrar que un teorema
debe ser válido siempre.
Una prueba clásica a menudo
atribuida a Pitágoras mismo
utiliza una estrategia llamada
prueba por transposición.
Tome 4 triángulos rectángulos idénticos
con longitudes laterales a y b
y longitud de la hipotenusa c.
Organizarlos de modo que sus hipotenusas
formen un cuadrado inclinado.
El área de este cuadrado es c².
Ahora reorganice los triángulos
en dos rectángulos,
dejando cuadrados
más pequeños a cada lado.
Las áreas de esos cuadrados son a² y b².
Aquí está la clave.
El área total de la figura no cambió
y las áreas de los triángulos tampoco.
Así que el espacio vacío en uno, c²
debe ser igual
al espacio vacío en el otro,
a² + b².
Otra prueba viene de su
compañero matemático griego Euclides
y también descubierta
casi 2000 años más tarde
por Einstein de doce años.
Esta prueba divide un triángulo
rectángulo en otros dos
y utiliza el principio de que
si los ángulos correspondientes
de dos triángulos son iguales,
la proporción de sus lados
es la misma, también.
Así que para estos 3 triángulos similares,
uno puede escribir estas expresiones
para sus lados.
A continuación,
se reorganizan los términos.
Y finalmente, se suman las dos ecuaciones
y se simplifica para obtener
ab² + ac² = bc²,
o a² + b² = c².
Aquí hay una que utiliza la teselación,
un patrón geométrico repetitivo
para una prueba más visual.
¿Puedes ver cómo funciona?
Detén el video un momento,
si quieres, para pensarlo.
Aquí está la respuesta.
El cuadrado gris oscuro es a²
y el gris claro es b².
El delineado en azul es c².
Cada cuadrado contorneado azul contiene
las piezas de exactamente una oscuridad
y un cuadrado gris claro,
probando de nuevo el teorema de Pitágoras.
Si realmente te gusta
convencerte a ti mismo,
podrías construir un plato giratorio con
3 cajas cuadradas de igual profundidad
conectados entre sí alrededor
de un triángulo rectángulo.
Si llenas el cuadrado más grande con agua
y giras el plato giratorio,
el agua del cuadrado grande llenará
perfectamente los dos pequeños.
El teorema de Pitágoras tiene
más de 350 pruebas, y contando,
que van desde lo brillante a lo oscuro.
¿Puedes agregar
la tuya propia a la mezcla?